avant le traditionnel conseil des
ministres emmanuel macron préside un
conseil de défense le premier depuis le
29 décembre dernier ils devraient
évidemment être question de la situation
sanitaire en france avec ce chiffre
20000 nouvelle contamination relevés
hier sur le territoire et puis une
inquiétude autour du bar ayant anglais
ducourneau virus qui est présenté comme
plus contagieux on sait d'ores et déjà
qu'il ya eu quelques cas confirmés en
france
ce qu'on ne sait pas en revanche c'est
le nombre de ces cas et sur quelle
partie du territoire il se trouve en
tout cas au royaume uni l'apparition de
cette nouvelle souche du coronavirus
coïncide avec une hausse très importante
du nombre de cas et c'est ce qui a
conduit le gouvernement britannique a
procédé à un recond finement pour une
période d'au moins deux mois ce scénario
semble pour le moment être écartée par
les autorités sanitaires en france qui
explique que les indicateurs de santé
sur le territoire sont moins dégradés
qu'outre-manche et puis ce conseil de
défense devrait également être
l'occasion de faire le point sur la
campagne de vaccination
après des premiers jours raté l'exécutif
tente de corriger le tir
olivier ferrand le ministre de la santé
multiplient les prises de paroles pour
tenter de rassurer en écosse d'ici jeudi
on va augmenter encore de façon très
importante
on va être sur une courbe exponentielle
rassurez-vous par rapport à cela
c'est à dire que la situation le rythme
de croisière de la vaccination en france
va rejoindre celui de nos voisins dans
les prochains jours il y aura une
inscription possible pour les français
qu'ils souhaitent par internet par
téléphone sans doute pourquoi pas tous
antico vide pour que les français qui
souhaitent se faire vacciner et puissent
le faire savoir
s'inscrire et puissent prendre des
rendez vous à noter que le premier
ministre le ministre de la santé
donneront demain une conférence de
presse justement pour parler de cette
campagne de vaccination cela pourrait
aussi être l'occasion d'annoncer de
manière officielle le report de la
réouverture des bars et des restaurants
dont la date avait uni
le mans était fixée le 20 janvier
prochain un scénario qui semble
aujourd'hui de plus en plus lointain